Bob my first question is how how does it
feel to be a world record holder I can't
feel anything much
it's just another fact of life what do
you put your longevity down to ah that's
what everybody wants to know
I'm the slightest idea good genes
I guess and I'm taking things to succumb
instead of worrying about them for
months and tell me over your life you
lived in Japan you spoke Japanese you
spoke Chinese yes
Taiwanese which was a dialect of China
yeah and tell me you've you're a
traveled man you've you've led a very
very interesting life Oh quite
definitely yes if you want my memoirs
I've got a copy right lend you but I
can't give it to you because it's a
limited print and tell me I see a card
from Her Majesty the Queen so that's
quite a year or two ago because I see no
point in her sending me one every year
for 10 years and tell me what this
younger generation nowadays what do you
make of modern life everyone under
iPhone's people vaping everyone in a
rush what do you make of modern one I
think there are some great drawbacks the
lack of actual personal contact add your
eye contact everybody's walking down the
street hold them of these things a bit
of this to their surroundings
and to people who knowledge so they
might walk by each other without
noticing who it was and tell me over
your life did you eat or drink anything
special was there any foods you avoided
or did you exercise a lot I ate what was
put in front of me no questions asked
and did you enjoy a drink oh yes but I
don't drink alcohol or only on occasions
like a wedding or or somebody's birthday
I would think but otherwise I'm not
addicted to it I think ever flower
cordial tastes a lot better and tell me
Bob over the course of your life through
so many incredible British landmarks and
world landmarks that you were there to
see and you remember and tell me about
the Zeppelin's rating hull
oh well the early ones were a total
surprise nobody thought that a
separating cross the null scene of a man
V Atlantic so nobody knew what to do but
they very soon organized something my
father was an air raid warden but when
the sirens went he was on with his
armband and his cap enough to do his
duty attending and we children were
brought down from the Attic and put
under the dining room table we had no
Anderson center centers or anything of
that sort any memories of World War two
where were you when war broke have many
more broke out I was on board a Canadian
liner in the middle of the Pacific on
the way home ostensibly to
Britain for Philip because I had been
away seven years but that's how I was
when we got to Canada
we were told full so you can't cross the
Atlantic so the rest of all I was
working in Canada and the United States
on various jobs different jobs for the
British government and when you came
home what what were your memories of
life post-world War two
in Britain post-world War two
first was the shock coming up the Solent
mm to see roofless houses acres of
rubble and everything else nobody that
that was after the war ended a sureness
occurred but there was some months
nothing had been done do you remember
Coronation day of the Queen yes Queen
Elizabeth the second I don't know that I
have any clear recollection but obvious
I must have box it on television can I
ask just you know you're what 10 10
years older than her majesty our soul
we're decade older and what's your
impression of the Queen and the life
she's lived and my impression of the
Queen is that she's about most sensible
person in Britain everybody else is a
bit mad and tell he loves a component
and and tell me I'm another great day
that stands out in the memory in this
country England winning the World Cup in
1966 where were you that
yes I was I was in living in London at
that time but yes 1966 or attend rates
in suburbs near Harrow in that sort of
area of London
do you remember watching the match oh
yes more or less but I couldn't tell him
any details Bobby Charlton and the rest
of them heroes
yeah and tell me other great events
royal weddings Charles and Diana getting
married do you remember do you remember
that day watching on TV when I was
getting married no Prince Charles and
Lady Diana oh yes I did but I wonder
said that was so outstanding it was a
great tragedy though there are certain
went wrong with the barrage and tell me
tell me about your family I was one of
seven children and my memoirs are
entitled we were seven and how many
children have you three
I had three one a boy unfortunately he
died a year or two ago with some
complaint that nobody understood that I
well but that was the sad part of our
life yeah but I had three children two
boys and a girl the first Sean the
oldest was born in Tehran the other two
the boy and the girl peach and also
boarding Canada during the war and tell
me I'm just gonna ask you a couple more
questions Bob and what advice would you
give to people nowadays who hear about a
man about to turn 112 and think maybe I
should make a few changes to my life or
be a bit a little bit less hectic and
maybe live longer what advice would you
give to the younger generation well I
don't give people advice because a if
they don't like it they don't do it and
if they do do it and it turns out bad
you're to blame so I don't give advice
but I make suggestions and tell me when
the Guinness Book of World Records get
in touch in March to confirm that you
were the world's oldest man
oh they have they already have so tell
me how how do you feel I suppose I
should used to it and what's not
anything that I've wanted for a long
time or a [ __ ] that's all yeah
if you keep on living eventually you are
the oldest person tell me who's your
favorite actor oh not a living one I
wouldn't think who was it I don't know
favorite fella so you think about
English quite a bit before I was
shattered and tell me
do you follow sport much oh yes
football whole surge a whole city where
I was born there your football team yeah
they're not doing too badly and then one
final question and what are your plans
for the rest of the year then as the
world's oldest man how do you feel
people have changed and how they
speak to you or well that remains to be
seen doesn't it I see gentlemen in Japan
who just died and made it feasible I
don't feel I want to take advantage of
somebody's death